as let's take to you to arm man in
Jordan we've been waiting for that press
conference by the US Secretary of State
Anthony blinkin who's joined by the
foreign minister of Jordan Iman Safari
and the foreign minister of Egypt Sam
shukra this is after a round of
diplomatic talks that uh the US
Secretary of State has been having uh in
the region with Arab leaders uh who are
determined that there should be a
ceasefire but he is maintaining the US
and Israel stance that there should be
no CE
farc
excellen I the other colleagues the I
welcome of uned the fore Ministers of
Egypt and Saudi Arab United Arab
Emirates and also the Secretary General
of the Palestinian Authority at this
dire
moment where our human
values historic relation and ongoing
relation ations and our Keen our
keenness to protect and Safeguard all
our people from the uh repercussions of
War all this dictate that we must work
together to put an end to this disaster
that erupted on October
7th and
exaggerated to reach that point with the
Israeli War on Gaza Gaz
and we spoke today
candidly with
veracity and was
extensive and in absolute
transparency we
Meed our
positions compared to the different and
counter different positions
yet we shared our keenness to continue
to engage intensively in order to put an
end to that what cannot be described
than a catastrophe that will haunt the
region for generations to come we all
seek just and permanent peace on the
basis of the two-state solution as a
Lynch pain to the security of the region
and the security of the Palestinians as
well as the Israelis let alone the whole
peoples of the region during the meeting
we have some converging
views I
mean between the US position and the
position expressed by the Arab foreign
ministers at presence during the meeting
these points included the necessity to
deliver Swift and continuous relief Aid
to Gaza resumption and continuous of
Human Services protection of
civilians total respect to the
international law and humanarian
release of captive civilians and a
rejection of forceable transfer of the
Palestinians out of their Homeland this
is what is shared by our brothers in
Egypt and the same is reiterated by us
here in Jordan it is yet another War
crime which we will address by all means
conceivable the Arab states called for
an immediate
ceasefire as we continue to see
civilians killing on by the minute and
we reject to label it as a selfdefense
it is a pleasant War targeting and
killing civilians destroying hospitals
uh mosques churches schools and it
cannot be justified it will not bring no
security to Israel it will bring no
peace to the region The Killing must
come to an
end the War Machine
must come to an end also Israel's
impunity against the international law
also cannot be tolerated and must come
to an end now I will speak to English in
English we cannot
allow this war to all that has been done
to bring about just peace to the region
with every missile Unleashed on Gaza
with every killing of a Palestinian
child and Israel has killed in this war
more children than all Global conflicts
did since
2019 the whole region
sinking in a sea of hatred that will
Define uh generations to come uh that is
already starting to manifest
itself uh in expressions and acts of
hatred in the region and to be honest in
the deplorable acts and expressions of
islamophobia and anti
semitism and and that's something that
we all stand against unequally
unequivocally on principle and in
accordance with our human values uh this
is not a religious War it's not a war
between Muslims and Jews this is defined
in its context and all our values Muslim
Christian Jewish all other human values
uh uh dictate that we work for peace and
we stop this madness and we do not allow
for for for the very dangerous
dehumanization that we
see
uh rage cannot and should not be allowed
to destroy the lives of millions of
people we understand there is pain
nobody in their right mind will belittle
the pain that was felt by Israelis in
October 7 and that's being felt by
Palestinians and all of us it doesn't
matter of who we are Arab Muslims
Christian Jews human being uh that pain
cannot be belittled but again we cannot
allow rage uh to determine where we go
forward we condemn the killing of all
civilians we condemn the killing of
Palestinian civilians we condemn the
killing of Israeli civilians on October
7 and before and after regardless of of
nationality as I said
uh we're extremely worried uh on this
situation in on the West Bank uh again
killing and and violation of
international law cannot continue There
settlers should not be allowed to
Rampage Palestinian communities and kill
Innocents in the West Bank uh Israeli
soldiers who brought despicable
humiliation on Palestinians after
illegally uh uh detaining them should be
held accountable Palestinians and
Israelis are deserve to live in peace
with dignity with security and freedom
from occupation and Freedom From Fear
only a just and Lasting peace that
fulfills the right of the Palestinian
people to Freedom their service state
with the East Jerusalem as their capital
in June 4 1967 lines living side by side
a secure Israel will bring security to
all the priority now is to ending this
War uh to saving innocent lives to
preventing further destruction to
restoring hope and to stopping the very
dangerous
dehumanization all lives matter to all
of us and uh Mr secretary dear Tony the
US has a leading role to play in these
efforts and on it and on all of us uh
fall the a very heavy responsibility of
ending this catastrophe achieving the
just peace that is the right of uh every
Palestinian every Israeli mother child
father and that will ensure that none of
them or any other in the region will
ever have to live the horrors that this
vicious cycle of violence and War uh is
bringing we will continue to work with
you and with all our partners to fulfill
this responsibility to make sure that
our common human values Prevail
international law prevails and peace for
all Prevail thank you so much if I now
may get the floor to you
Tony good afternoon everyone and let me
first say that I'm grateful to Majesty
King Abdullah uh to far Minister Safar m
and his entire team for their
hospitality and for the opportunity to
be with Farm Mr shukri and also with for
Minister
fan uh prime minister Alani for Minister
abdulla zad and Secretary General hus
alake um we appreciate the engagement of
every country here and we're
particularly grateful to Jordan and to
Egypt two partners who have long worked
to advance the two state solution with
their dedication to a more stable and to
a more peaceful Middle
East we come together here
today uh sharing the same fundamental
interest and
objective to end this conflict in a way
that ensures lasting peace and Security
in the region we may have different
views and positions on certain necessary
steps to achieve that
objective but today we reaffirmed our
individ ual commitments to continuing to
work toward that end an end that we
share throughout this conflict countries
across the Middle East and Beyond have
played an essential role in preventing
its spread today we all agreed on the
importance of using our respective
influence and capabilities to deter any
state or non-state actor from opening
another front in this conflict or taking
other destabilizing actions all of us
have a direct interest in
this our joint efforts have also been
critical in increasing the flow of
humanitarian assistance to Gaza I'm
particularly grateful to Egypt for its
significant effort to facilitate a
mechanism with Israel and with the
United Nations to do just that each day
more than 100 trucks are moving to Rafa
up from zero just a little over a week
ago but that is not nearly enough today
we spoke about ways to accelerate and
expand the sustained delivery of
Aid this morning I had an opportunity to
meet with commissioner general vazarin
of unra and I spoke with unra staff that
is located in Gaza I heard firsthand
about the extraordinary life-saving work
they're doing in Gaza in the face of
extremely difficult conditions and how
we can expedite efforts to get
assistance to them so that they can get
it to the Palestinian people we're also
working to continue the progress we've
made in getting our citizens other
foreign Nationals critically wounded
people out of Gaza but even as we
welcome their safe exit we remain
resolutely committed and focused on
securing the release hostages held by
Hamas I had the opportunity to discuss
this in the status of our ongoing
efforts with prime minister Alani this
morning we all spoke today about the
clear need to protect Palestinian
civilians United States stes supports
Israel's right to defense against theas
terrorist organization that attacked it
brutally and that cares not a wit about
the Palestinian people or their
future this is the same right that each
of our countries
have but as Israel conduct its campaign
how it does it
matters Israel must take every possible
measure to prevent civilian casualties
in my meetings with Israeli officials
yesterday I conveyed additional steps
that they can and should take to do just
that protecting civilians will help
prevent Hamas from further exploiting
the
situation but most important it's simply
the right and moral thing to
do when I
see Palestinian boy or girl pull from
the wreckage of a
building it hits me in the gut just as
it hits everyone in the
gut and I see my own children in their
faces and as human beings How can any of
us not feel the same
way this morning I heard from the unrest
staff in in Gaza many of whom are
displaced themselves about the immense
human toll that this conflict has
taken for Honor itself they've lost 77
of their colleagues who were there
simply trying to provide people with
their basic needs
the trauma of being under constant
bombardment and in constant danger the
inability to assure their own children
that nothing will happen to
them what we have to
do more than anything else all of us
everyone
concerned is to prevent the de
humanization of each
other we don't do that we do exactly
hamas's work for it so we have to look
out for each other we have to look out
for every innocent
life now the United States believes that
all of the these
efforts would be facilitated by
humanitarian pauses We Believe pauses
can be a critical mechanism for
protecting civilians for getting Aid in
for getting foreign Nationals out while
still enabling Israel to achieve its
objectives to defeat Hamas
yesterday I spoke in depth with Israeli
leaders about how when and where such
Arrangements could be implemented and
what needs to be done to make them
possible today Regional Partners discuss
many these same
questions we're all deeply concerned
about escalating extremist violence
against Palestinian civilians in the
West Bank this has been a serious
problem it's only worsen since the
conflict I updated ministers today on my
discussion with the Israeli government
yesterday where I underscored that
incitement and extremist violence must
be stopped and perpetrators must be held
accountable as we work together to
address each of these immediate
challenges we also have to concurrently
work to build secure and Lasting peace
and for that to happen we have to create
the conditions to ensure that we do not
find ourselves in the same place just
weeks or months from now we had
substantial discussions today about our
shared interest in creating the
foundation for durable security and for
enduring peace the United States
continues to believe that so viable path
is a two-state solution with Israelis
and Palestinians each in exercising
their legitimate right to live in a
state of their own with equal measures
security of freedom of opportunity and
dignity and we discuss some of the
meaningful and practical steps that we
might take to help
advance that proposition to get us
there United States and our partners
will have different views on how best to
advance or achieve these
steps but we all recognize that we
cannot go back to the status quo and we
all understand that we not only have an
interest but a
responsibility to do everything we can
to chart better path forward
together now none of us are under the
illusion that this will be easy
particularly our partners from Egypt and
Jordan who have for decades worked to
facilitate a real peace but it's
precisely
now when the stakes are
highest even when the Outlook seems
darkest that we have to intensify our
work to meet this
moment thank you so muche uh uh time
my friend
Tony ladies and
gentlemen I extend all appreciation to
his Excellency man
sa Deputy Prime Minister and the
Minister of Foreign Affairs and exp and
other foreign ministers who were at
present today as we aimed at discussing
the crisis in Gaza allowing the Arab
countries in participation to express a
uniform position towards this crisis
during the meeting I was keen on
explaining and demonstrating Egypt's
view which is converging with that of
its Arab Brothers in addressing this
crisis I reiterated that the element of
time and the rapid development must be
taken into
consideration The Killing unfortunate
killing taking place in Gaza cannot be
justified we cannot accept to engage in
useless wrangling or an attempt to let
these
practices unnoticed as if it is a lawful
Act of self-defense the policy of
collective punishment and the targeting
of innocent
civilians innocent civilians civil
buildings hospitals and Par Medics and
rescue teams in addition to the
forceable transfer of the Palestinian
out of their Homeland cannot be deemed
as lawful Act of
selfdefense Egypt is sparing no effort
in receiving and delivering the relief
Aid to the gazans allowing the exit of
those requiring medical medical
attention Egypt will continue with its
related efforts despite the huge and
numerous obstacle
within this context I reiterated that
it's necessary to
achieve a unanimous agreement on a
permanent and Lasting ceasefire without
any restriction or condition and that
Israel cease of violating the
international law humanitarian law and
War related convention and act swiftly
to ensure the continuous and constant
delivery of relief Aid in quantities
that would meet the basic needs of our
Palestinian Brothers paving the way to
examine how to exit this crisis before
the circle of violence expands and the
conflict
undermines the safety stability and
security of other peoples of the region
plunging the whole region into a dark
tunnel I also called for ceasing from
addressing the issues undermining
International Peace and security with du
standards as many hardly condemned the
targeting of
civilians
calling any act of violence against them
as flagrant violation of the
international
law H in calling for ceasefire in other
crisis we see the same parties when it
comes to the Palestinian cause turning a
blind eye to it as if the blood of the
Arab human is of less value than his
fellow human considering that the number
of fatalities among civilians over the
past few weeks
including those working relief Aid and
journalist
cannot be justified under any claim or
pretext in this context we still
continue to demand a Swift and permanent
ceasefire and prevent Israel from
blocking the of relief Aid and we also
demand International investigation of
this gross violation of the
international humanitarian law in this
war finally what we witness
unprecedented escalation unmatched UN
Human catastrophe people
suffering is the result and reluctance
from addressing the root cause of the
problem including the restoration of the
established Palestinian rights
I reiterate our total rejection of any
attempt to torpedo the Palestinian cause
at the expense of the Palestinian people
or the peoples of the region I I call on
all concerned to work immediately and
swiftly to revive the peace process in
on the two-state solution with an aim to
put an end to the Israeli occupation the
establishment of the Palestinian State
on the June 4th 1967 border with East
Jerusalem as its capital thank you Sam
and again thank you Tony thank you Sam
uh I'm sure the three of us would love
stay and answer all your questions but
we really have a very very tight
schedule still ahead of us so we'll take
just very very limited few number of
questions and I'd appreciate it of all
our colleagues would just limit their
their intervention to one question and
one question only uh sfan can you please
uh we call start with the Middle East
News
my question to the
Egyptian Minister Mr
sh today's meeting comes at a very
significant
time especially that uh high level of
officers were were at Presence uh do you
think or did you feel today that the US
Administration has a genuine political
will or for the
ability to put an end to the continuous
violations against the Palestinian
civilians in
Gaza and did you chart any road map plan
for the Revival of the peace process to
put an end to the current
crisis I believe it is not
suitable to speak about the US position
in presence of the secretary of state
but I can say that we had in-depth
extensive uh discussion with absolute
veracity uh and transparency as we all
share the same genuine desire to act
effectively to put an end to this Crist
and lay down the solid foundations and
solutions that will spare the entire
region from further
conflict uh we reiterated that
all issues and crisis must be dealt with
in the same standards aiming at
safeguarding civilians and delivery of
relief Aid at the same time we should
also address the the root cause of the
crisis despite the long
outstanding
Decades of reluctance from establishing
and enforcing what has been agreed upon
namely the establishment of the
Palestinian state this will
aggravate the
crisis and will lead to further
repercussions we look forward to working
closely with the United States we
have our
bilateral relations and we also
appreciate the efforts and resources of
the United States there is no doubt
there has been a great concern and our
me views were meeting to a large degree
and we will work on the coming days in
order to
frame uh these views and translate them
into actions on the ground it is a
grinding humanitarian crisis and it
should be dealt with
positively not only the current crisis
but also the original root cause
thereof Simon leis
Reuters hi um thank you yeah one
question but uh but I'd appreciate an
answer from all of you if possible um to
the Egyptian uh and Jordanian ministers
specifically um are you engaging in
talks about the future of Gaza a future
of Gaza without Hamas uh and what role
you can play in that future and
secretary blinken um you know how do you
respond to the calls for from your
allies here for a ceasefire um and and
are you hearing um are you finding
receptive uh uh ears for your calls to
talk about um Gaza after Hamas
thanks Simon thanks very much for the
question
uh it's our view that uh the ceasefire
now would simply leave Hamas in place
able to regroup and repeat
what it did on October
7th and you don't have to take my word
for it just a few days ago a senior
Hamas official said that it was their
intent to do October 7th again and again
and
again no Nation none of
us can accept that no one would find
that
tolerable uh and so it is
important to
reaffirm Israel's right to defend itself
indeed its obligation to do so and to
take necessary steps so that October 7th
can never happen again but it's also
very important the way Israel does that
and that's what we've talked to the
Israeli government
about uh with taking every possible
measure to protect human life to prevent
civilian
casualties as well as to ensure that
those who are in need have the
assistance they
need to that end I think we all share
deep concern
about the plight of civilians uh in Gaza
men women and children who
need most essential things uh to get by
uh we've worked very hard to make sure
that that assistance can flow to them uh
but it's also one of the reasons why
humanitarian pause would be so important
to make sure that we can maximize the
assistance getting to uh the
Palestinians that we can make sure that
people can move about safely uh that
they can get to places where they're
safe uh and uh that uh again we can make
sure that not only is Aid flowing in but
those who are responsible for
Distributing get in the right structures
can be built to make sure that people
can benefit from it so we're focused on
this um and we'll continue
the work that we're doing together with
our partners to make sure that that
assistant can get
there thank you
Tony right well as relates the the issue
of a ceasefire it is our position that
the ceasefire is imperative to deal with
the consequences the humanitarian
consequences of this conflict and we
believe that dealing with the various
components of this crisis should be
dealt with as well in an appropriate
manner but it is the international
community's responsibility always to
seek the cessation of hostilities and
not to promote the continuance of
violence military activity that has a
very uh dire impact on the well-being of
the civilian population in a very
restricted area uh and uh which has
specific and special characteristics
like Gazza as for the issue of the
future of razza I believe that this is a
premature at this time we have to
concentrate on the subject at hand
whether it be the cessation of
hostilities addressing the humanitarian
needs of the people of Gaza addressing
the uh issues of displacement and and
the provision of of safety for for the
civilians uh and addressing the overall
context of of the conflict uh I believe
that at this stage the those are the
issues that we need to concentrate on
thank
you thank you sir uh we're focused right
now on on stopping this war stopping the
the destruction it's causing stopping
the killing that it's causing what
happens next how can we even entertain
uh uh what will happen in Gaza when we
do not know what kind of Gaza will be
left after this war St uh are we going
to be talking about the Wasteland are we
going to be talking about a whole
population reduced to refugees simply uh
we do not know we do not have all the
variables to to even start thinking
about that uh I think we need to focus
now on stopping this war so at least we
have a uh uh we start even to begin to
imagine the kind of miserable reality
that will exist there and after that let
me just be very very clear Gaza alone
will just not got it we've been through
security uh treatment of the conflict
before where did it lead us the only way
going forward to achieve what we all
want which is a just and Lasting peace
that protect the rights of all is to
look at the comprehensive conflict uh
look about bringing the two-state
solution back and and realize it as soon
as possible convincing the Palestinians
that they have a future and uh con and
and and again creating uh conditions uh
uh uh different from from the miserable
conditions of Despair and and anger and
and and and hatred and and and and
occupation in which the this vious uh uh
cycle of violence erupted so I think we
need to get our priorities straight
right now we have to make sure the war
stops right now we have to make sure
that we bring in sufficient uh if enough
food and water and medicine and fuel to
Gin because with every minute of delay a
child or a woman or an elderly is dying
because they don't have access to these
to these uh basic services so after that
uh again we have to look at the
comprehensive picture we have to make
sure that we do not contribute to
creating the same conditions that in
which this violence erupt
and I think we are all committed uh to
working together on that as we always
say the United States has a leading role
we need that role the rest of us will
have to do our our part as well
everybody will have to do their part
again to make sure that uh we bring the
security and peace to uh to to the
Palestinians and to the
Israelis georan
television thank
Mr
blink why is not Washington pressuring T
Aviv to
seize um the war and allow the delivery
of AIDS after the killing of
9,500
Palestinian thank you uh we are
intensely focused on the delivery of
humanitarian assistance um on my last
trip to the
region I spent considerable time with
the Israeli government and then in
consultation with um the uh Egyptian
government the United Nations on
establishing uh a channel to make sure
that we could get assistance into people
who needed it in Gaza and as I mentioned
a short while ago uh whereas just a
little over a week ago nothing was
getting in we had zero trucks moving in
today I think we had 105 trucks
uh move in uh to uh to Gaza with
essential needs for people but as I also
said and as we all agree that is not
nearly enough so what we're working on
now is expanding uh that access making
sure that more is getting to people who
need it and that we have the structure
in place to be able to uh to absorb it
to uh to use it uh to distribute it
effectively um this is exactly what
we're doing when I was in Israel
yesterday this was a big focus of my
conversations with the Israeli
government um and it's also as I
mentioned one of the reasons why we
think it would be important to have
humanitarian pauses that would further
facilitate the ability to deliver Aid
and not only to deliver Aid again to
expand uh the aid that we delivering so
uh we're we're looking to that we agreed
with um the government of Israel
yesterday
uh to look at how that uh might happen
there are a lot of questions that have
to be answered about how to make that
work so we're focused on on doing that
but again we have been intensely focused
on getting humanitarian assistance to
people who need it in
Gaza question
um alaz
television
my question is addressed to secretary
Clint blinkin after almost a
month on the Israeli War on Gaza what
are the results achieved by Israel other
than killing almost 10,000 civilians
mostly women and children what are the
other achievements gained by
Israel and what is the number of
fatalities most ly civilians that
will push the United States to pose and
reconsider its position towards this
prgram and decisively ask Israel to put
an end to this Bloodshed and break The
Siege late to
Gaza what took place on October
7th
defies almost the human ability to
digest or
describe
and I think for many that day has
receded in their minds and in their
Consciousness but I can say this and
I'll say it again not a single one of
the countries represented here or that
met together today or for that matter
pretty much any country in the world
and simply accept the slaughter of its
citizens and do nothing about
it so you maintain again that Israel has
a right and indeed an obligation to
defend itself uh and to try to take the
steps necessary to ensure that what
happened on October 7th never happens
again but equally it is very important
how Israel does this and in particular
it's important to take take every
possible measure to protect civilians
and prevent harm to them as well as to
ensure that those who need assistance
get it and in our conversations with the
Israeli government uh including just
yesterday uh we have pointed to steps
that they could and should take to
minimize harm to civilians to prevent
civilian
casualties
now this is
also an extraordinary challenge Hamas
cynically monstrously embeds itself in
the midst of
civilians puts its Fighters its
commanders it's weapons it's ammunition
it's command and control in residential
buildings under schools and in
schools under hospitals and in
hospitals under mosques and in
mosques it's
monstrous but
nonetheless Israel has an obligation to
abide by the laws of war humanitarian
law and to do everything possible to
prevent civilian casualties and this is
very much part of what we're saying to
the Israeli government and what I said
again
yesterday the same
time providing humanitarian assistance
to those in need making sure that men
women and children in
Gaza cared for this is also an intense
focus of our actions including with the
Israeli
government thank you and uh before I
close I just want to reaffirm once again
that we're going to continue to work
together uh Bridge whatever gaps we have
in our position because ultimately we
want the same thing but again I just
want to say uh one thing imagine you're
a Palestinian father mother you have to
leave your your your home and the
already miserable existence of a refugee
camp in Gaza you take your kids to the
South you take shelter in a hospital and
you're looking at your ey at the eyes of
your children and you know you cannot
protect uh you know that you cannot find
a place where they can escape the
bombing how do you explain to these uh
that this is helping us how do you
explain to a father whom we saw in CNN
yesterday in the rubble looking for four
children of his that are still buried
than the rubble and he cannot he cannot
find them I think we need to remind each
other of our Humanity uh I think we need
to uh accept that uh killing more people
will not bring those who are lost on
both sides as tragic as the loss is I
think we need to all emphasize that
everything we can do to save one more
life is imperative upon all of us I
don't want to go into characterization
of what the international law says about
that and what the international law says
about this but I would say what we all
as a human beings as you said as Sam
said as we all say as human beings we
just can not accept to see all that
killing unfolding to see all that
reduction of life to to a complete loss
how is how how can we justify to anybody
that killing 9,000 people killing 3,700
children uh destroying 150,000 house
killing destroying hospitals how can we
justify that this is self-defense I
think let's let's get back to the basic
let's step back and and take a pause and
again we all understand the pain but we
are this world just going to produce
more pain for Palestinians for Israelis
and this is going to push us all again
into the abys of hatred and
dehumanization that will make killing
even more more acceptable so that needs
to stop that's our priority it has to
stop now it has to to end and we should
all work for a future when a Palestinian
child sees an Israeli child they see in
each other a potential friend not a
future enemy I I think that's what we
need to do and I look forward to working
with all our colleagues and friends here
to create that reality and just once and
for all uh in the need for War and the
need for violence and and in conditions
in which only uh uh misery and and and
and and an environment that that enables
uh the kind of extrm that produces Ben
and smork also on the side of Israel
that that will also end
thank you so much
appreciate